you scared for who if you were white or
if you were black
he cared if I was white because I think
I should be winning this position but
I'd see all sorts of ways I could lose
it
that's true I mean it's so difficult to
assess right exactly I know like you put
it into the engine it's just all so easy
but um that's dangerous yeah
no question at the board and white funds
of nowhere right now not yet absolutely
yeah so I don't know
yeah interesting one still plenty to
play for in that one but Patrick I mean
another victory for you yesterday you
played all the way until the last final
yeah it was a tough game I was actually
pretty proud of my game yesterday it was
a great game by the way sorry to
interrupt this one is over I think Kirk
got another Victory a difficult one I
have to say he was completely losing out
of the UK but Patrick back to your game
yeah this was the big moment right here
when he decided to take Rook takes C3
yeah how did you assess it at this point
how would you decide to go for this
queen C3 Queen C7 okay were you worried
about that so scroll back two moves yes
okay right here right I played Bishop C4
after a long thing okay and I did not
see Rook AC 8 Bishop B3 Rook take C3 and
then and then I played the move and I
was like oh no and so while he was
thinking I was thinking even though I'm
walking around I was like I spent like
whatever it was 15 minutes thinking
because if you have to take with the
beep one yes yes I see right yes so well
if I if I take with the B Pawn I think I
lose immediate with Knight takes E4 but
um but um instead what I I thought I
could play Bishop takes F6
um Bishop takes yeah exactly I thought I
could play this position but I didn't
want to play this position yeah so I
look at the eval bar it says it's equal
forget about it but I you know I mean
these these positions are often okay for
white but Black's having all the fun but
then I saw Queen take C3 and the more I
looked at it the more I liked it
um and it works I I think it just works
it does yeah and this was the critical
moment at this point
he got a bit greedy to keep the Queens
on the board Queen to E7 was the only
way to continue this game yeah that made
sense to me and then I thought Queen E5
yes 25 I go back Bishop F5 were right
yeah and even here like I could even go
Rook takes F5 I think that position like
maybe it's not completely correct I
don't know but it's a very it's a much
easier like white is better for sure
because eval bar yeah yeah like white is
always better yeah yeah yeah
so I wasn't afraid of this and then he
played Queen G6 and I saw this through
takes F7 tactic
oh wow oh yeah this is over after this
oh I didn't realize it was that good
when when you're sitting and calculating
it's not that clear Unstoppable yeah
Rook F7 is just uh killing yeah that
tactic with rookie one is very pretty I
was very pleased when I saw that yeah
that yeah this I calculated all the way
and then I I also if you go back there's
this he can also try this bishop takes
C2 check at the left Point uh yeah so
you can like here yeah but I think so I
can take with the bishop yes but I can
also I think take with the King okay
let's see
Queen takes and uh go up and go up yeah
so the evil bar doesn't like it as much
that's interesting it just thinks the
position of the bishop takes C2 is
winning so you have to go yeah
king of okay some crazy moves yeah king
of faith is the only way to not die no
no but well but you you do die right
because it's Queen
right that's the only way not to die
well Bishop takes up seven yes Queen F7
oh yeah yeah yeah sure sure we play this
position yeah sure sure that's right
yeah yeah it's not that easy of a
conversion right I mean yeah King is
still a bit weak
although I suspect it's actually not
that bad but anyway I think but if you
go back it looks like I had better
um I mean this is the nice thing is like
I don't have to worry about it I can
just let him move and then I'll decide
but if you go back instead it took one
move
well yeah uh yeah Queen takes E6 Bishop
C2 check
and does it just want me to take with
the bishop yes yeah yeah it's just that
it's just that good huh I mean it looked
like it was going to be very good yeah
um and I guess the only question is what
to do after king of Faith right yeah
because if it goes into this end game
this is hopeless yeah yeah yeah but king
of f8 it seems like Rook D1 oh my
goodness Rook D1 is just winning
so easy when you've got this right now
no but I mean I knew this position was
very good right because his light
squares were infinitely worse than my
dark squares
um and um yeah it was really interesting
how somehow it became a Sosa and I mean
Dimitri and I have played so many of
these classical Sicilians sometimes
they're rousers and in the old days I
mean 30 plus years ago they were sozens
and we must have had five or six dollar
mirrors attacks so it's very funny that
somehow this became kind of like a Susan
but this Rook takes F7
um yeah and Yasser was praising your
style saying that you're extremely good
at direct play what is working better
that's a very very nice way to say that
I'm very one-dimensional
oh
what's the difference in the second part
of the event compared to the first part
of the event what's working better
you know I mean I I make I've been
making this joke for the last couple of
days that I've been shaking the rust off
and I feel like by the time the
tournament ends I'm going to be ready to
play and
um I think I was just really rusty and
um you know my first game against Kai
done off I literally I mean he surprised
me in the opening he played he played
Bishop E3 which I did not expect in the
night of and I just forgot the line I
just totally forgot the opening and then
against Max I had a perfectly good
position and just like really didn't
like stop at the critical moment Queen
takes D4 was terrible right Bishop H6
was very good and then against
um uh uh shabalov well I played the
opening badly he outplayed in the
opening but then on top of that
um I played this movie Bishop takes H6
which is right idea wrong execution
completely what I should have done is
like Queen E3 first yeah King membership
A6 and I realized afterwards you know
part of getting back into the rhythm is
being sort of aware of like the tension
in the game and like the critical
moments and the emotion and just sort of
like and this it's hard to explain with
words but anyone who plays chess sort of
like just understands this right you
just sort of have to get into the feel
of it and um you know I I the last
couple games I've gotten into the feel
of it Mike I was very very happy with my
game against Joel because he completely
surprised me in the opening and I played
my line but it's a position I've never
played before I I thought really really
hard
um I got slightly outplayed a slightly
better position at one point than I was
slightly worse but I held and I saw I
was lose I was I was low running low on
time I managed to time pretty well I
checked it afterwards I think it was it
was a very well played game by both of
us actually I don't think there were any
real mistakes that gave me a really good
feeling you know and then of course I
just hope for the best I prepared for
the game he completely stepped out of my
preparation and we got a fight and my
one-dimensional Approach my very direct
play was very uh was very uh successful
in this game so I was very happy Patrick
congratulations thank you great Victory
we'll see you in the next throughout
thank you very much I hope I'm back
thank you Patrick indeed we have a
couple of results including